traditionally a symbol of surrender
but in malaysia a white flag has come to
signify a cry for help
the campaign started on social media
after stories emerged of people
experiencing hardship
because of the continuing lockdown
police recorded nearly 470 suicides
in the first five months of this year
compared to an average of 620
in the past two years michael adams tang
worked in a hotel until he lost his job
last year
he then started delivering food but is
finding it increasingly difficult
to make a living
in this third lockdown not only are
there fewer jobs
but food orders have also reduced so my
income has gone down
we don't make enough to pay rent we only
have enough to eat
for the day malaysia's borders have been
closed for more than a year
and even though some states have started
easing restrictions
a nationwide lockdown announced in june
is still in force
people have responded to the plea for
help in various ways
restaurant owners have set up food banks
and are giving out
free meals business is bad
sales are down nearly 90 percent but we
are seeing so many people in it
so my friends and i pulled money
together to help
and soon customers started contributing
as well
some have created apps to link people
who need assistance
with those who can provide it there are
donation drives online
to help people pay rent and other bills
but the white flag campaign has also
started another trend
directed at those in power the economic
distress
and desperation has fueled resentment
towards the government
a social media campaign is calling on
people to fly a black
flag as a symbol of their anger
their calls for the prime minister muay
than yasin to resign
his biggest coalition partner a party
known as amnor
says it's withdrawing support for him
muyden's leadership
cannot be tested until parliament
resumes later this month
but for those trying to survive from day
to day
politics is the last thing on their mind
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur